TO COVET NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WHO
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND ADHERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE ARE
HOLDING A COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE CAPITAL TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING. A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND WILL BE
ANNOUNCED RIGHT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-336-4437 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT
FOUR TWO EIGHT ONCE AGAIN.
EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT FOUR TWO
EIGHT FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE
SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE SEE THE
SENATE AND OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
A MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET WITH THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING ****
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAPTIC ACTIONS. WHAT
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARING CENTER
THAT'S CLOSEST MANNER. AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LACK TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENTLY WAIT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY WE HAVE TWO BILLS AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT AND AP. ONE
FOUR SIX SIX PLEASE NOTE THAT
A. B. THREE SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOHN SAWYER
PREVIOUSLY NOTICED TO BE HEARD
TODAY HAS BEEN PULLED FROM A
HEARING AND MADE. A TWO YEAR
BILL. FIRST LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AS NO CURRENT CAN BE
ESTABLISHED AT THIS TIME WE
WILL PROCEED AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. UNTIL WE GET A
FULL QUORUM WE WILL BEGIN FIRST
WITH A B. ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY PETRY NORRIS WELCOME
THEN YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SAG
GOOD MORNING I AM HERE TODAY TO
ASKFOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. AND BEFORE
I BEGIN MY PRESENTATIONS I
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND TO ADD TO
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFERS YOUR
HARD WORK ON NOT. ON ADVANCING
THIS LEGISLATION AND DIE
IMPROVING IT IN THE IN THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS. FIVE THE
GOAL OF AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
IS TO IMPROVE PATIENT
PROTECTIONS AND INCREASED
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE FOR
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
SEEKING SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT. THROUGHOUT THE CABIN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE HAVE SEEN
A PRECIPITOUS RISE IN DRUG AND
ALCOHOL ABUSE AND IN THE NUMBER
OF PATIENTS THAT ARE SEEKING
RECOVERY AND SO THIS MEASURE IS
MORE IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL
NOW. THAN EVER BY AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT WILL INCREASE
STANDARDS IN THIS INDUSTRY BY
ESTABLISHING MINIMUM INSURANCE
COVERAGE LEVELS FOR LICENSED
DRUG ABUSE RECOVERY AND
TREATMENT FACILITIES. AND FOR
RECOVERY RESIDENCES THAT
CONTRACT WITH THE GOVERNMENT.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LARA ON
THIS LEGISLATION AND PLEASE TO
NOW WELCOME FOR TESTIMONY. MIKE
MARTINEZ. FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. THANK YOU BEFORE
WE PROCEED WITH OUR WITNESSES I
WOULD LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME NOT TO EXCEED THREE
MINUTES ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THEM. THE MEASURE AGAIN WE WILL
BEGIN WITH A MICHAEL MARTINEZ
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE A SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU TO
REVIEW GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL MARTINEZ
HERE ON BEHALF OF. INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA. AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE I WILL BE BRIEF. AS
THE BILL'S SPONSOR COMMISSIONER
A LOT I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
FAMILY MEMBER PETRI NORRIS. FOR
HER LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. COMMISSIONER
LOTTE IS SPONSORING THIS BILL
BECAUSE HE WANTS TO ENSURE.
THAT ADEQUATE AND REASONABLE
INSURANCE STANDARDS EXIST. FOR
THAT THERE'S A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT FOR CONSUMERS TO
GET THE TREATMENT THEY NEED.
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
THEIR SAFETY ESPECIALLY DURING
A TIME WHEN MORE CALIFORNIANS.
ARE SEEKING ASSISTANCE DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC. I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK
WITH US ON A. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT AS THIS BILL. CONTINUES
TO MOVE THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MARTINEZ WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TWENTY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SCENE NINE WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. C. NINE NINE
FINALLY WE WILL MOVE ON TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY AT THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AP LEVIN FIFTY
EIGHT. AND OPEN THE LINES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THOSE
INSTRUCTIONS ARE ONE ZERO.
WE'LL GO FIRST ONLINE THIRTY
EIGHT THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIRTY EIGHT THREE. ARE
YOU IN SUPPORT OF A B. ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT. HEARING NO
RESPONSE THAT WAS OUR ONLY LINE
IN Q. YOU MAY CONTINUE THANK
YOU MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE OPPOSITION WHICH WILL BE
GIVEN EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME I
DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTER EAT
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE GALLERY. FOR
ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION C. NINE WE WILL
NOW MOVE OVER TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SEEING NONE. WE WILL
NOW MOVE OVER TO TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR. IF A PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE THE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AT
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ME
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S A ONE MANY. ZERO WE HAVE
NO LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE WILL NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS
HAVE WHO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR-
WISHING TO SPEAK. ARE THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
MILES'S ARE TAUGHT ABOUT BEFORE
WE MOVE FORWARD. WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RUBIO THE PRESIDENT RUBIO
PRESENT JONES ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA PRESENT BAIT HERE
BATES PRESENT FOR JUST. DOT
GLAZER THE WAITER. HER DAUGHTER
PRESENT WITH OUT OF HERE
MELINDA'S. FORTINO. ZERO HERE
ROB. YOUR BREATH HERE. WE STILL
DON'T HAVE AN ESTABLISHED
QUORUM BUT WE WILL PROCEED AS A
SUB COMMITTEE I WOULD GIVE US
THE OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I SIMPLY. ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WEWILL LEAVE THIS OPEN FOR A
QUORUM AND FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
OPEN SORRY I MESSED UP SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU I JUST HAD A
QUICK QUESTION BECAUSE I WANT
TO- THE PRECIADO A FAMILY
MEMBER BETWEEN OURS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE- LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SOBER LIVING
COALITION REEF IN OPPOSITION
ARE. A CONCERN- INITIALLY IT
LOOKS LIKE IT'S BEEN A DRAFT BY
JUST WANTED YOU TO OUR FIRM.
HOW YOU DEAL WITH THAT IN TERMS
OF THEIR CONCERN ABOUT THE
SMALLER HOMES IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THEY'VE BEEN. THERE'S BEEN
SOMETHING LESSER THAN A FULL
COVERAGE INSURANCE POLICY BEING
REQUIRED FOR THOSE SMALLER. THE
CORRECT YES AND SO ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALLOW FOR I REQUIRE
GENERAL LIABILITY INSURANCE FOR
SMALL FACILITIES A SIX HUNDRED
TO BE INCLUDED. OR ADDED ON AS
A WRITER TO A TYPICAL
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY INSURANCE.
POLICY GREAT THANK YOU. I AM.
F. ESTIMATE MEMBER I'M SORRY
CENTER BATES AND- AS I STATED
EARLIER- WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE WILL CONTINUE. WITH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO. AP.
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX. BY AFP
MCCARTY. WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE HI THIS IS
A BILL THAT WE HEARD IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE A FEW WEEKS
AGO AND DO WANT TO THANK THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE STAFF AS
WELL THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
STAFF WORKING WITH US TO
INCORPORATE AMENDMENTS WE THINK
MOVE THIS ISSUE FORWARD. THIS
IS RELATED TO THE ISSUE WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT CALIFORNIA
RACIAL JUSTICE AND RACIAL
RECONCILIATION AND OUR POLICY
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO HOUSING
IN THESE- RACIAL COVENANTS OR
ON HOMES FOR DECADES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT RESTRICTED
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND- WE AGAIN WE
DO HAVE WORK WITH AMENDMENTS
WITH WITH THE COMMITTEES AND BY
DOING SOME WORK WITH THE-
PARTIES AND STAKEHOLDERS ON ALL
SIDES AND WE THINK REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION WE'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM ONE OF THE GROUPS HERE IN
A BIT. AS WE KNOW THESE
RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
WERE PRIVATE AGREEMENTS BARRING
NON WHITES- AND OTHER
INDIVIDUALS FROM OCCUPYING OR
OWNING PROPERTIES THROUGHOUT
OUR NATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND A KEY ELEMENT. OF OUR
SEGREGATIONIST POLICIES OF THE
EARLY TWENTIETH CENTURY. NUMBER
EXAMPLES THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES- I COULD MEMBER I
TOLD THIS THIS THIS BODY A FEW
WEEKS AGO THE- THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHEN I BUY MY OWN
HOME. OUR REALTOR CAME TO ME
AND SAID I KNOW YOU'RE FROM A
MIXED RACE FAMILY BUT THIS IS
GOING TO REALLY INSIGHT TO HAVE
A LOOK AT PAGE. FIFTY SEVEN OR
SOMETHING AND SEE THAT SAYS YOU
ONLY HEAR ONLY PEOPLE THAT CAN
BUY THESE HOMES ARE WHITES AND
I WAS FLOORED THAT THESE WORDS
WERE STILL IN THE DEEDS OF
HOMES. LATER THEY WERE STRUCK
DOWN BY THE SUPREME COURT BUT
THEY STILL EXIST IN THE STING
IS STILL THERE FOR MANY PEOPLE
WHEN THEY SEE THESE ARE BY
THEIR HOMES. SO WITH THIS BILL
IT'S REALLY TWO FOLD IT'S GOING
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
HOMEOWNERS AN INDIVIDUAL TO
TAKE PROACTIVE STEPS TO REMOVE
THEM. AND ALSO WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A PROCESS- WHERE WE
CAN TAKE A LOOK AT ALL OF THESE
DEEDS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN STUDIED TO IDENTIFY
MAPPED IN SUFFOLK SUBSEQUENTLY.
REDACTED THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP OF WRITING A PRIOR WRONG.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BRING AN
ANSWER TO ALL THE ISSUES AS FAR
AS- RACIAL HOUSING POLICIES BUT
IT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP. IN AND-
WITH ME TODAY ARE TWO
INDIVIDUALS I'D LIKE TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
THIS MEASURE THANK. I THANK YOU
AND AGAIN BEFORE WE CONTINUE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE MAKE THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT AND AGAIN DUE TO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS EACH
WEEK TERM INTO TWO TIME LIMITS.
AT THIS TIME EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME NOT TO EXCEED THREE
MINUTES EACH ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MESSING WITH THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. WE WILL MOVE UP FIRST
WITH- JAMIE LEWIS. I BELIEVE
THAT YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU THIS IS
JAMIE LEWIS. THANK YOU CHAIR
RUBIO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX AGAIN
MY NAME IS JAMIE LEWIS. AND I'M
A RESIDENT IN TENNESSEE BUT BUT
CALIFORNIA. I MOVED INTO WHAT'S
CALLED THE IN HOME DISTRICT AND
FAMILIES THE BEST PHONE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. WHILE I WAS
PREACHING PURCHASING MY HOME I
WAS FILLING OUT THE FACT PEOPLE
WORK MY REALTOR SHARED WITH ME.
AND MY FUTURE HOME COVENANTS
CONDITIONS AND RESTRICTIONS.
READING THROUGH THESE I WAS
APPALLED TO FIND A PROVISION
PROHIBITING ANYONE OF A NON
CAUCASIAN RACE. FROM OCCUPYING
OR OWNING THE HOME AND LIKE
THEY WERE AT THE MEXICAN.
READING THROUGH THESE I AM
SORRY I KNEW THAT I WANTED TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE C. C. N.
R. BUT I WASN'T SURE WHAT. THEN
IN THE WAKE OF GEORGE FLOYD
MURDER I HAD A MOMENT OF
RECKONING WHERE IT BECAME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR. THAT THE
RACIST LANGUAGE IN NINETY THREE
IN OUR IN THE MURDER OF BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE AT THE HANDS
OF THE POLICE. ARE ALL A PART
OF AMERICA'S MULTI FACETED
RACIST PAST AND PRESENT. THIS
IS WHEN I BEGAN THE PROCESS OF
HAVING THAT LANGUAGE REMAINS. I
STARTED SPEAKING TO NEIGHBORS
ON EVERYTHING THAT THESE
COVENANTS ARE PERVASIVE
THROUGHOUT THE N. HOME
DISTRICT. DESPITE KNOWING YOU
HAVE AN INTERNAL LAUNDRY LEGAL
OR ENFORCEABLE IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
TO UNSEE SOMETHING. OUTWARDLY
PREJUDICE. THE COMPOSITION OF
MY NEIGHBORHOOD IT'S THE DIRECT
PRODUCT AT THE C. T. AND OURS.
WITH 88% OF PEOPLE LIVING IN
HELLO BEING WHITE. FOURTEEN AND
I WERE ABLE TO GET LANGUAGE
REMOVED. ENGAGING AN
UNCOMFORTABLE BUT NECESSARY
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
COMPOUNDING IMPACT THE CCN
OURS. HOW THEY BARRED BLACK
FAMILIES FROM ACCESSING WEALTH
APPRECIATED OVER GENERATIONS OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP- ME REMOVAL OF
THESE CABINETS IT'S A SMALL
STEP IN ADDRESSING THE MUCH
LARGER IMPACT SYSTEMIC RACISM.
HOWEVER IT IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN ELEVATING THE MUCH NEEDED
CONVERSATION AND A KNOWLEDGE
MEANT THAT SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
PRIVILEGE. ADMITTED THE CCN
OURS UNDERSCORES HOW MUCH WORK
STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
PROVIDE RACIAL EQUITY IN THE
UNITED STATES I. JUST WANTED TO
REMIND I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT
YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND A HALF
AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A SECOND
WITNESS WAITING IN THE QUEUE
JUST AS A REMINDER SORRY FOR
THE INTERRUPTION. OF COURSE.
THAT'S OKAY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF THE P.
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS LIKE MYSELF GET
THE LANGUAGE GERMAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NOW WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE TO MICAH MODELS FROM ALL
HOMES ALSO WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. YOU MAY PROCEED.
ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU SO MUCH CHAIRPERSON AND
RUBIO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I WANT TO FIRST
THANK ASSEMBLYMAN ASSEMBLYMAN
MCCARTY FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. MY NAME IS TO MICAH
MARKS AND I IN. THE ETHNICALLY
IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SIXTY SIX. AS MY COLLEAGUE JEFF
DESCRIBE THE DISCRIMINATORY
LEGACY. THAT REVERBERATE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT SEGREGATION. BUILT IN AND
BAKED INTO OUR HOUSING
POLICIES. IT'S WHY WE SEE SUCH
A- DOT- YOU KNOW TO CONTINUE I
DISCRIMINATION IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY ACCESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
ALL HOME IS AN ORGANIZATION
THAT FOCUS ON FOCUSES ON
REGIONAL SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. AND HOUSING
INSECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS IS
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THESE
TYPES OF PRACTICES WE BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE WORK FROM
PROHIBITED FROM GENERATING
RESOURCES ASSETS AND WEALTH IN
COMMUNITIES THESE TYPES OF
COVENANT ARE THE REASONS WHY
OUR COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE. AGAINST
PROPORTIONATELY STRUGGLE WITH
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
INSECURITY IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
REDLINING MAPS IN OUR OVER
CONCENTRATION OF POVERTY IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS NO
COINCIDENCE THAT THESE MAPS
ONLINE. THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE DISPARATE IMPACT ACCESS.
TO HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE THE COMPANY LIKE THIS
AND SO I THINK IT IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT STEP TO NOT ONLY TALK
ABOUT IT BUT TO BE ABOUT IT AND
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION GIVES
OUR OUR POLICY MAKERS AS WELL.
OKAY SOME OF YOUR COMMENTS
SIGNAL. THANK YOU THAT THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT I HOW STANCE
FOR AND WE ARE IN PURSUIT OF A
MORE JUST AND EQUITABLE STATE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT AND
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD ON LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JONES DOES HERE BORDERS. DOT
BLAZER GLAZER HERE WHAT'S UP.
MELINDA'S. WE HAVE A CORE A
CRIME HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED NOW
WEWILL MOVE ON TO THE GALLERY
ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. C. NINE WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. THIRTY NINE WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO SUPPORT WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY GET
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WE NEED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE FOUR
SIXTY SIX- YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL CAN YOU PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN THAT'S A
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WELL THE FIRST ON LINE
FORTY SIX FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR WE ARE IN A UNIQUE
TWEENER POSITION COULD WE BE
AFFORDED ABOUT TWENTY SECONDS.
AT NO PLACE AT THIS TIME WE
ONLY CAN AFFORD FOR YOU TO
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU. OKAY I'VE
GOT THAT IT'S ROB GROWS CLOSER
WITH EACH COUNTY RECORDS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA-
HOPEFULLY MOVING GETS FOUR
POSITION WITHIN NINE MONTHS.
HOWEVER I WILL- WHEN WE MOVED
TO- THE OPPOSITION I WILL GIVE
YOU SOME TIME IF YOU WANTED TO
DIAL BACK IN THANK YOU-
NEGLIGENCE CASE. THANK YOU LINE.
TWENTY NINE. CAROLINA DUDE ON
BEHALF THE ACLU COUNT ACTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY
SIX. ANASTASIA YOGA NOVELIST
MEMBER OF RACE AND EQUITY AND
ALL PLANNING COALITION SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BORN IN. FORTY THREE. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS LESLIE VASQUEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE. FORTY TWO. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ANNA BACK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND WE ALSO HAVE A
CLEANER POSITION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
PRODUCTIVE WORK WITH THE DOCTOR
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT. NO
FURTHER LINED IN QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU TO THE ALL
THE PEOPLE THAT CALLED IN AND
SUPPORT I WOULDN'T HAVE ANY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION BUT AT
THIS POINT WE WOULD LIKETO GET
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY TO ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION- WE HAD A GENTLEMAN
THAT WISH TO SPEAK. YOU MAY
PROCEED. YES MA'AM SURE CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. YES MY NAME IS
CRAIG PAGE IN THE ZIKA VICE
PRESIDENT AND COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION UP UNTIL A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO WE WERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL BUT WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND THE CENTURIONS COMMITTEE.
WE'VE WORKED ON A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHORS
AGREED TO ROLL INTO THE BILL
THAT ARE MOVING US INTO A-
SUPPORT POSITION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING FORWARD-
TOGETHER WITH. OTHERS IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE
PROACTIVELY ON A GO FORWARD
BASIS THE LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
WILL PROMPT MODERATOR PLEASE IF
YOU PLEASE FROM INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. ONE FOUR SIX
SIX. THANK YOU TO STATE
OPPOSITION TOWARDS THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF NUMBER FORTY SIX. I
APOLOGIZE ONLINE IS NO LONGER
IN Q. NOW IT'S BACK. HERE ARE
NINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU R. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROB
GROWS UNDER THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION AND THAT
TWEENER POSITION- THIS IS A
GOOD BILL IN A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND WE THINK
THE DILEMMA FOR RUNNING IT- ONE
OF THE AREAS THAT WE ARE STILL
WORKING OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH
FUNDING MECHANISM FOR THE TASK
FORCE- WE ENCOURAGE YOU SOME
AMBER AND ACTIVE COMMITTEE. TO
MAKE THE FEE ON THE RECORDED
DOCUMENTS APPLICABLE TO ALL
DOCUMENTS THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL IS FAIRLY
AGGRESSIVE ENOUGH THAT HE WOULD
BE APPLICABLE TO AFFIDAVIT THE
DEATH MECHANICS GOING INTO
DOCUMENTS LIKE THAT BUT IT
WOULD NOT APPLY TO REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTIONS SUCH AS THE
PURCHASE OF A MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR HOMES. OR A VERY
SIGNIFICANT COMMERCIAL PROPERTY
AND WITH THAT AGAIN WE DO URGE
YOU TO PASS THE BILL BUT ALSO
ENCOURAGE THE. CORRECTION TO
THE MECHANISM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- AT THIS POINT WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THAT THREE MINUTES-
IT'S FEEDING TIME AT THIS POINT
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE JUST TAKE
YOUR NAME. AND YOUR POSITION
YOU MAY PROCEED. MODERATE
ONLINE ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
YES LINE. FORTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING ANNA BACK AGAIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE ALSO HAD AT IT
BETWEEN POSITIONS- WE LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR ALL
OF HIS WORK ON THE BILL AND BUT
IN ORDER TO MOVE TO A FULL
SUPPORT POSITION WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
REMOVAL OF THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF REALTORS TO ASSESS THE HOME
BUYING WE NEED I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT I NEED TO MOVE TO
JUST STATING YOUR YOUR POSITION
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU.
PRETTY CLEAR SUPPORT OF AMANDA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. JUST TO
CLARIFY IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS THE
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR AHA NOW HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL TESTIMONY I WILL NOT
BRING IT BACK TO DISCUSSION TO
THE MEMBERS IN THE FOR ANYBODY
WISHING. TO COMMENT I WILL GO
TO SENATOR ARCHULETA YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FORWARD- IT IS
ABOUT TIME. IT'S A RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS CONDITIONS THAT ON
PROPERTIES AND OBVIOUSLY THAT
GO BACK IN AND AFFECT SO MANY
MINORITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND BUT FOR THE
BENEFIT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS THE BOARD I THINK
FOURTEEN A. B. FOURTEEN SIXTY
SIX IS THE RIGHT BILL THERE'S A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST POINT OUT. THAT I
AM NOW IN TOTAL SUPPORT-
HOWEVER I DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR- FOR THE AMENDED SAFE
TAKEN AND HOPEFULLY THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT. THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE REALTOR
AND OR BROKERS AND AGENTS.
HAVING TO- PUT THEMSELVES IN
POSITION TO DEAL WITH THE R. C.
M. FORM. WHICH IS THE- THE
RESTRICTIVE COVENANT
MODIFICATION FORM THAT I DON'T
THINK THE REALTOR SHOULD HAVE
THAT RESPONSIBILITY NOW THAT
THERE'SA TASK FORCE THAT WILL
BE WORKING TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS. OF THE LOOP ELIMINATING-
THESE ITEMS ON THE DEEDS SO
CONSEQUENTLY HOPEFULLY THE
AUTHOR CAN WORK WITH THAT AND
MAKE THAT PART OF THEIR
AMENDMENTS IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE I KNOW THE- CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. IS
ALSO LOOKING IN THAT DIRECTION
AND IF- HAVE SUPPORTED THE BILL
NOW BUT WITH THE CHANGES I
THINK WOULD BE FULLY FULLY
COMPLETE AND I DO ASK FOR AN
EYEFUL. THANK YOU SENATOR HATCH
LETTER WILL NOW MOVE OVER TO
SENATOR WEBSITE YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
MAKING STUFF AVAILABLE IN
DISCUSSING THE BUILDING. HI I
HAD SOME CONCERNS CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL JUST SIMPLY IN
REMOVING INFORMATION THAT CAN
BE USED TO- CONTINUE TO PROTECT
HOMEBUYERS FROM DISCRIMINATION-
YOU KNOW I KIND OF A LIKE
CANADA CAN TOO IF YOU REMOVE
INFORMATION ABOUT A CRIME
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING INTO- A
INTO THE SCENE OF A CRIME AND
REMOVING FINGERPRINTS SYSTEM-
AN OFFENSE THAT A CONCERT
OCCURRED IN HISTORY. AND THE
AUTHOR SHE HEARD ME THAT- THAT
IS NOT THE CASE WITH THIS BILL
I HAVE ONE LAST QUESTION THAT'S
JUST A- ONE LAST THING I DIDN'T
ASK IT AND- MY QUESTION IS
REGARDING IF SOMEBODY. SOMEHOW
LOOKS AT THIS AS A POINT OF
PRIDE AND SAID YOU KNOW I. MIEI
OF PEOPLE FROM MY COMMUNITY
COULDN'T LIVE HERE IN THE PAST
BUT NOW I CAN. CHOOSE TO LEAVE
THAT INFORMATION IS IT IS IT
OPTIONAL THAT SOMEBODY COULD
APPLY TO HAVE IT REMOVED OR IS
IT WILL IT BE REMOVED FOM ALL
PROPERTIES WHEN THE CHANGE
CHANGE HANDS. SO INDIVIDUALS
CAN DO IT ON THEIR OWN RIGHT
NOW TO REMOVE IT OKAY BUT WHEN
THEY DO REMOVE IT IT'S STILL ON
THE BACK DEED WITH THE COUNTY
IT'S KIND OF LIKE WHAT I SAID
IF YOU PULL UP A BILL TODAY
THAT'S BEEN AMENDED YOU SEE THE
CURRENT VERSION YOU CAN GO LOOK
AT THE MASSIVE CHANGES WITHOUT
YOUR BILL PEOPLE COULD REMOVE
RESTRICTIVE COVENANT LANGUAGE
FROM THE ORIGINAL DATE CORRECT
THEY CAN DO TODAY AND THE FACT
THAT HALF OF THE BILL. WE WANT
TO MAKE IT EASIER WAY THERE WAS
A PRIOR BILL ABOUT TEN YEARS
AGO WHICH ALLOWS PEOPLE TO DO
IT IN ONE COUNTY IS DIFFERENT
THE OTHER COUNTIES SO IT'S NOT
COMPLICATED HER FROM THE FIRST
WITNESS THEY CAN DO IT BUT IT'S
NOT ALWAYS A MISSING WAS
PROCESS SO WE WANT TO DO TWO
THINGS ONE MAKE IT SO IT'S- CUT
OUT THE RED TAPES YOU OUGHT TO
GET MULTIPLE NOTARIES TO DO IT
ON YOUR OWN AND WE WAIVE THE
FEES FOR THAT AND WE'VE AGREED
TO THAT OKAY THE SECOND THING
IS THERE'S MASSES THAT DON'T
EVEN KNOW ABOUT. IN THE FIRST
PLACE SO THAT PART OF THIS BILL
IS THAT WE WOULD CREATE THIS
FIND WE WOULD IDENTIFY AND MAP
THEM AND THEN WE CAN REMOVE
THEM AT LARGE SLOTS BUT TO YOUR
POINT WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE
THEY'RE AT AND MAYBE HAVE
PUBLIC POLICY TO PUT MORE
RESOURCES IN AREAS WHICH DID
HAVE- A CONCENTRATION OF THESE
CABINS BUT IF AN INDIVIDUAL
WANTED TO SEE THAT STILL. THAT
RECORD WOULD STILL EXISTS FOR
ETERNITY THEY COULD GO AND FIND
IT AT THE COUNTY RECORDS AND
HAVE THAT STUFF SO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS THAT THEY CAN APPLY
FOR THIS OPTIONALLY CONTINUING
IT GOING INTO THE FUTURE IS NOT
GONNA REMOVE BE REMOVED
AUTOMATICALLY. WILL STILL BE AN
OPTION OF THE BUYER- IT DID
THIS PART HOW BEEN DETERMINED
YET SO WHEN WE HAVE THIS FUN IN
THIS FEE THAT PAYS INTO IT WE
GO AND MAP ALL THESE ONE NIGHT
ONE THING THAT I THINK THAT
THAT WE WOULD WANT TO DO IS
CLICK REMOVE A MALL IN MASS
LIKE A CERTAIN AREA AND SOME
PART OF SAN DIEGO MAYBE THERE'S
A COMMUNITY THERE WITH THREE
THOUSAND HOMES AND THEY ALL
HAVE I- BUT I GUESS WHAT YOUR
POINT IS IT WOULD AFFECT
INDIVIDUAL WANTED TO. SOMEHOW
SEE THAT AND BE ABLE TO SORT BY
PRICE HEY I OVERCOME ALL THIS
IN THE PAST FIFTY YEARS I WAS
ABLE TO BUY THIS HOUSE ON A
HILL AND HERE WE ARE TODAY- THE
POINT I WAS TRYING TO MAKE IS
THAT THEY WOULD STILL BE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY THAT RESTRICTIVE
DEED BECAUSE IT WOULD STILL BE
AND LIKE THAT ESSENTIALLY BACK
TO BACK AT THE AT THE COUNTY
OFFICES AND MY SECOND QUESTION
IS REGARDING THE KIND RECORDERS
AND AMENDMENTS THAT DO WERE YOU
AWARE. THAT THEY HAD SOME
CONCERNS REGARDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF FEES IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT JUST THAT JUST
POPPED UP OR WERE YOU AWARE OF
THAT YES SIR IF YOU RECALL I
THINK THREE YEARS AGO WE HAD A
BIG BILL BY THE PRO TEM
CHARGING A FEE ON ON REAL
ESTATE TRANSFERS TO PROVIDE
MONEY FOR HOUSING THE ENERGY
NUMBER IN THAT WE HAD WE HAD
WE'RE WE ARE NEARING THAT
POLICY THAT'S ONE ONE ONE OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
REALTORS ANOTHER SYSTEM HERE WE
HAVE THAT- THE RECORDERS HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION ON THAT.
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO RECONCILE
THAT SO WE'RE STILL OPEN MY
QUESTION WAS WHAT YOU WERE WERE
YOU AWARE OF THAT OR SYSTEM
THAT WAS BROUGHT UP TODAY NOW
THAT WE WERE WE'VE BEEN AWARE
THAT THE SHE FOR SO YOU'RE JUST
NOT AN AGREEMENT WHERE THE
WHERE THEY'RE COMING FROM TERMS
OF THEIR AMENDMENT CORRECT
WRIST YEAH THERE'S DIFFERENCES
OF OPINION SOME OF THE OTHER
GROUPS THAT ITHAT TESTIFIED
THAT REMOVER OPPOSITE IN
SUPPORT NOW THEY ACTUALLY LIKE
THAT PROVISION WHICH WE HAVE A
OKAY A DIFFERENTIAL FEE
STRUCTURE BASED UPON WHAT WAS
IN THE PRETENDS BILL FOR THAT.
THE HOUSING OKAY VERY WELL- ALL
SPORTSBOOK TODAY WHICH LIKE TO
HAVE THE METAL ON THE BILL
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING I WILL GO BACK TO
SENATOR ARCHULETA. YES MAY I
WANTED TO CHECK WITH YOU
AUTHORED WE'RE ON THE- PLANE
HERE THAT- WITH WHAT I'VE JUST
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE. THAT
IN FACT THE REMOVAL ACROSS THE
BOARD. IS GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
THIS- TASK FORCE. BUT AGAIN I
EMPHASIZED. THAT THE REALTOR
SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM ANY
RESPONSIBILITY. AND PUTTING THE
RCM FORM TOGETHER AND BEING
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT. ARE YOU-
YES I DON'T WANT TO BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH US ON THAT YEAH THAT
IS. DEFINITELY PART OF THE BILL
THAT'S PART OF THE AMENDMENT WE
ALREADY TALKED YES. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU-
IF ANY MEMBER WISHES TO SPEAK
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AS IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO SEE YOU I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER HANDS UP. I
WE WILL- WELL FIRST OF ALL I
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR ALSO BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I UNDERSTAND. MY
APOLOGIES TO THE TWEENER IS
SUCH AN INTERESTING POSITION TO
BE IN. A BUT I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT- THE AUTHOR IS WILL
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATIONS OUT
NOT ONLY WITH THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S OFFICE BUT- BUT THE
REALTORS AND DIES SO I WANT TO
THANK HIM FOR THAT TIME WITH
THAT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU THIS ITEM THIS IS A
PROBLEM WE ALL REALIZE IS
THEY'RE- HAVING THE REMEDY TO
ADDRESS THIS IS- CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT IS BEEN ELUSIVE-
FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER HECTOR
DILATORY. WHICH I THINK-
REPRESENTS THE SAME AREAS MR
ARCH ALETTA AND THAT. SOUTH
PART OF LA COUNTY. TRY THIS TEN
YEARS AGO- WE DID NOT SUCCEED.
THIS IS NOT A NEW ISSUE BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW IN THIS AREA
WERE AT LIKE THE WITNESS QUOTE
FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO. WE'RE
TAKING A HARD LOOK AT THESE
THINGS I THINK WE WANT TO.
PRESERVE HISTORY BUT ALSO LOOK
AT OURSELVES AND THINK HOW CAN
WE- MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE-
RACIALLY SOUND HOUSING POLICIES
THIS IS NOT A PANACEA. IT'S NOT
GOING TO MAKE. HOUSING MORE
AFFORDABLE IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES ARE ACCESSIBLE FOR.
CAN USE A COLOR BUT- IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RIGHT A WRONG I
THINK WE FOUND THE RIGHT MIX
AND THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THESE AMENDMENTS. ASKING
RIGHT. THANK YOU AT. THIS TIME
MAYBE FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX HAS
BEEN- SENATOR WAS. COMES PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RUBIO HI RUBIO HI JONES JONES I
ARCHULETA HI OR TO HI BASE.
RIGHT BATES HI BORDERS ARE
BORDERS I TODD GLASER. LASER HI
LISA WHY SO HI HER DAUGHTER HER
DAUGHTER HI MELINDA'S. FORTINO
UNTIL I BROUGHT. HI. BILL HAS
TEN VOTES. THIS BILL HAS TEN
EYES IT HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT
WE WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL
FOR US TO MEMBERS HA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AT THIS POINT WE WILL
GO BACK TO THE PREVIOUS BILL AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT R. SINCE
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RUBIO. CAN. I'M
SORRY DO YOU MIND REPEATING
THAT ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU RUBIO
HI REVIEW BY JONES JONES HI
ARCHULETA. ACTUALLY I BATES
BATES BY BORDERS BORDERS HI
TODD GLAZER GLAZER HI WAY SO
WAS SO HIGH RETARDER. TOTAL HI
MELINDA'S FORTINO. REPORTING BY
ROUGH SPOTS I. BILL HAS TEN
VOTES THE BILL ITSELF TEN ZERO
I'VE BEEN INFORMED AT THIS TIME
SENATOR MELINDA SINCE SENATOR
DOG WILL NOT BE COMING BACK SO
AT THIS POINT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE ON THIS BILL ARE WE WILL
OPEN IT UP ONE MORE TIME. FOR
BILL. AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DOT OF
MELINDA'S BILL HAS TEN VOTES
THIS BILL ITSELF TEN ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THIS. AT THIS
POINT WITH THIS IS THE
CONCLUSION OF OUR COMMITTEE
THANK EVERYONE THAT
PARTICIPATED AND HAVE A GOOD
DAY THANKS. WE ARE ADJOURNED.